hallo an alle bürger herzlich willkommen
wir heute sagen neuen videos
wir haben hier heute eine cap
vorbereitet wo gibt es eigentlich gar
nicht gibt so gar nicht auf jeden fall
jeder sechs aufgaben reingepackt die wir
vorher auch über papier geschrieben
haben das heißt wir spielen jetzt ex
klub und der verlierer muss immer eine
aufgabe ziehen und die aufgabe muss dann
bewältigen muss die erste aufgabe ziehen
freunde spricht 60 sekunden im rhein
jetzt für die fortlaufende videos oder
jetzt allgemein jetzt nur jetzt jetzt
jetzt jetzt so lange ich muss sonst gibt
es verträge ausgesprochen gut und weg
haben wir diese tolle zu treffen haben
wir spielen lieber räuber und gendarm
wirklich cool wird ein rein nein
schreien jetzt ein thema damen und
herren wir schauen uns in welchen drin
steht und war dabei eine luftblase mit
dem kopf platzen wenn irgendwas mit den
kopf platzen zu lassen sie auf dem boden
haben 2000 jahre später
das dienst nicht auseinander was
verstehst du ja da ich etwas sage immer
wenn der andere deinen namen sagt
ich hoffe ich jetzt meine sache von mir
weil die sind zumindest nicht so dumm
und scheiße ich widme twitter die letzte
worte nachricht von dir o
was war das substitution zu dirty talk
ein paar sie können den später wissen
auf dem letzten zeit eine letzte
nachricht also die letzte nachricht
eigentlich sprachen aber die letzte
wirkliche textnachricht war in die
gruppe von mir hilfst du bezahlt so viel
für adapter okay leute ins geschehen
du bist so viel für adapter habe ich
gerade auf twitter rausgehauen ich würde
sagen wollte einmal applaus was sagst du
magst sollten mit sagen leute ich bin
schon seit relativ langer zeit wach habe
gelernt geschrieben mit schön klingen
unterwegs und jetzt hab ich mir gedacht
ich habe heute wieder nichts kommt nach
ich wenigstens irgendwas deswegen bitten
jahre über schatz ich hoffe dass das
kriegen was ich drauf geschrieben hat
oder barbies bestimmt das hat mir dies
bestimmt ich mache nicht weil ich dass
die leute mich hatten werden aber ich
sage trotzdem pizza ist scheiße war's
neue werkzeuge wie es ausschließen und
hebe läuft besucher aufgerufen
doch er verlor den puck eheleute
nebensache von ihren stühlen die
entscheide von lucanet ich hab die extra
wenig in die spülmaschine geräumt weil
ich dachte dass du das dann spielen muss
diese schriften für dein outfit passt da
sich alle tariflichen mehr gemacht er
groß wir hoffen dass man ganz nah hier
die anführer angeht wäre es wasser fiel
gerecht auf dem schwamm laufen
einfach leicht aus dabei fiel komisch
und verstärkt und dann die schlüssel
umdrehen
ermöglicht wird mal vorstellen lukas
alleine gegessen
einfach nur eine folge nicht mal welche
2004 allein drei menschen
loki max alba wieder technisch noch ihre
papiere erst mal wieder verloren musste
team des herzens sein direkt relativ
ausgeglichen mit dem verlieren gewinnen
von schere stein papier schreibe 13 auf
twitter schreibt sie dass ein tri tra
die cousins oder als favoritin zu den
estrich aktiver fan nummer eins raus
nummer zwei ist raus und nummer drei
wenn er zu diesem zeitpunkt gefragt habe
was ist das für ein video was ich gerade
frauen seid euch gewiss dass wir immer
gesagt dass wir es schaffen
vielleicht mag ein audi mit ein
skateboard heute wissen selbst geld weg
fährt aber es ist immer wieder wichtig
dass man genau das richtige schuhwerk
trägt damit zu einer echten so thome die
nase vorne
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
die leute hier sind beide todes am a ha
ha
die soko die romantisch wenig konnte ich
gehe aber widmen
es ist leichter wenn ihr euch wünscht
ihr wert jetzt ukulele
also leute wir ziehen die geräte
wir machen jetzt die drittletzte
challandes auf meine damen und ich bin
sehr gespannt was da drin steht und zwar
nehmen beim nächsten mal schwein ja
entweder von deiner dümmsten aktion
aller zeiten gottes immer richtig
schwierig wenn er immer so sagen muss
aller zeiten bei der dümmste aktion
aller zeiten war eigentlich glaube ich
sondern das wie nach amsterdam gefahren
bin so spontan und unglaublich einfach
ins nichts geschnitten haben wir haben
schon verhältnismäßig der in der deal
führen und hält er sich glauben die
dümmste aktion meines lebens warten er
nach amsterdam fahren und fünf sterne
hotels gegeben für eine fackel kannst du
selbst bewegt und die letzte sache und
weil dann steht wieder starten hat die
usa an bord und die koalition stelle 50
[Musik]
doch jetzt mal so erwartet hiervon
winter gefallen lassen die zeichen dafür
[Musik]